drew bearmore reunited with her
ex-husband tom green for the first time
in person after nearly 20 years the
former couple tied the knot in 2001 but
their marriage was short-lived as they
were divorced by 2002.
yeah joining forces on the drew
barrymore show with frequent guest rob
matthews the duo reminisced on their
honeymoon in ireland and shared what it
was like to see each other after all
this time
remember the road trip that we took um
through ireland yes absolutely yeah
remember we for some reason decided to
hike up to the top of a mountain we
hiked up this crazy mountain for hours
hours and we just were determined to
reach the top but at certain points i
don't think we thought we ever were
going to i remember a couple of things i
think we might have hiked up two
mountains i remember one mountain we got
to the top that was foggy and there was
a sheep up there that hadn't been shorn
in years and it looked like it was out
of
and headstones it was there was a little
there was like a
it was a mini cemetery yeah absolutely
and then a storm came in yeah and we had
to run down the mountain yes yes but we
like just jumped in random oceans and
found random fields it was it was a nice
trip it was like one of my favorite
trips of my life that was our honeymoon
it was our honeymoon by the way and it
was a good one yeah it's very nice to
see you it's really it does feel weird
though it does not weird in a bad way
weird in a good way yeah appreciate it
droops thanks for uh thanks for having
me on the show it's awesome this is this
is this is cool this is i mean i
actually think this is kind of
a nice way of reconnecting actually
takes a little bit of the pressure off
well i respect and love you